hey guys my name is just I'm Dan and you
are watching games but news for all the
things have been happening today tune in
the next three to four weeks
Clippy be the developer behind Gears of
War recently returned to the gaming
landscape with war breakers
unfortunately things aren't going quite
as well as you'd hoped
according to steam charts and law
breakers active players on PC has
dropped to only 215 as of writing it's
worth noting that this is only the PC
stats as numbers aren't available for
the ps4 version of the game though we
here at GameSpot spent over half an hour
in matchmaking on ps4 attempting to get
a game we were unsuccessful again this
isn't hard evidence as boskie have
commented that they're aware of issues
affecting matchmaking and have laid out
plans to address them as part of the
games roadmap lawbreakers launched just
a month ago on August 8 to positive
reviews with GameSpot reviewer Miguel
Concepcion awarding the game at 8 and
saying one sign of any worthwhile
team-based shooter is a level of
accessibility where everyone feels they
can contribute no matter their play
style and law breakers succeeds in this
manner boss cave outlined new maps a
competitive mode and a new class that
they plan to bring to law breakers
before the end of the year so fingers
crossed this one finds an audience if
you follow those does PR VP Pete Hines
on Twitter then you were probably privy
to the back and forth over whether the
publisher is actually going to bring out
a new unannounced game this year during
an interview with youtuber mr. Matty
plays Hein said we even have a game
coming out this year that we haven't
even told anybody about yet so they can
wait it won't be so long when prompted
to explain if the game will be new IP
Hein said he wouldn't offer up any more
information the internet was then led to
believe Hines misspoke as he commented
that he was rambling and advised people
to ignore him he later clarified that he
was making a joke and Bethesda do have
an unannounced game on the way this year
so with all that out the way what do you
want to see from Bethesda this year I'm
gonna keep saying Elder Scrolls 6 even
though I know we've got a while to wait
on that one but those are also have
Wolfenstein 2 when you Colossus arriving
on the 27th of October and the evil
within too is hitting shelves on October
13th
now that we've raised you up let's take
it out the animated Batman invoice of
the Arkham games Dark Knight Kevin
Conroy has said that Warner Brothers is
not making any more Arkham game
when asked by a crowd member at the
Nashville Wizard World Comic Con if
anymore Arkham games are in the works
Conway responded you know I can't
believe that they're not going to do
another one but they're not isn't that
amazing
they made literally billions of dollars
on those games but no there's no plan to
do another one
sorry Rock Steady's finale Arkham Knight
wrapped up the love story of births and
the jerk up pretty neat late but there
was speculation that a side storyline
could happen what about this games
Montreal were responsible for the
prequel Batman Arkham origins that saw a
younger greener Batman taking on his
rogues gallery on Christmas Eve but it
looks like nothing more is going to come
from Batman at least in the foreseeable
future let us know in the comments what
you'd want to see from a new Batman game
or what you'd like to see Rocksteady
tackle next that's everything we have
for you today to enjoy the rest of your
day and make sure you subscribe to see
us every day of the working week
bringing you all the gaming news you'll
ever need yes we'll catch again tomorrow
and what do you want to say well Skyrim
really you know it's not Skyrim - if you
say that you'll anger them masses I just
want more Skyrim on more things or more
devices if I can't play Skyrim every day
on everything I own you already can't